foreign
product lead for the go programming
language at Google I'm here to talk
about some of the new and upcoming
security features in go and how you can
use them to write more secure
applications
later in this presentation my colleague
Cody will join us to demo some of the
features we discuss so stay tuned for a
proper example
developers and companies often choose go
for its performance readability
Simplicity and scalability but more than
ever they're also choosing go because of
its security
when we say security we generally mean
one of two things the first is detecting
and remediating known vulnerabilities in
your dependencies
let's start by describing the problem
say you're writing a package a and to do
so you depend on several other packages
which provides some functionality they
in turn might also depend on packages as
well and so on
now let's say there's a vulnerability
deep in your dependency tree deep and
far away as it is this vulnerability
might have consequences for your project
that's because the problem is an
isolated package K it could affect I and
it could affect BCD or e
worst of all it could affect you because
of a problem in some Leaf package you've
never even heard of
with the web of dependencies relying on
other dependencies getting larger and
more complicated there are lots of
places for a bad actor to stuff a
vulnerability that affects wide swaths
of a language ecosystem
this is in part because dependency
graphs can be complicated making
vulnerability detection and in radiation
intractable
you may think your dependency graph
looks like this but really it looks like
this dependency graphs are complex
directional graphs the rendering on this
slide describes kubernetes
in go we solve for this problem by
addressing it for the whole ecosystem
with Go's new vulnerability management
system now in preview you can check your
entire dependency graph against our
curated database of vulnerabilities and
fixes
vulnerability data comes from existing
sources like cves and ghsas as well as
direct reports from go package
maintainers this information is then
reviewed by the go security team and
added to the go vulnerability database
in order to read these vulnerabilities
programmatically you can use the GoPhone
DB client which is how we recommend that
you read from and interact with the
database you can also review the
database directly in your browser from
the go package site at package.go.dev
phone
we also provide a volume check API which
tools like the visual studio code go
plugin will soon use to provide
vulnerability detection and Remediation
directly from your IDE
finally we provide the go volt check
command which provides a low noise
reliable way to find known
vulnerabilities from the command line
unlike other Solutions which might warn
you of every vulnerability throughout
your dependency graph whether or not
they affect you call Von check analyzes
your code base and only surfaces
vulnerabilities you actually invoke
based on which functions in your code
are transitively calling vulnerable
functions
vulnerability management helps you
detect and fix your exposure to known
vulnerabilities but what about
undiscovered vulnerabilities say the
ones that might exist in the code you're
writing for that we have fuzzing fuzzing
is the process of testing your
applications using automatically
generated inputs derived from coverage
feedback and other signals
fuzz testing is well suited for reaching
those edge cases which developers often
miss which makes it particularly
valuable for finding security exploits
and vulnerabilities
go supports fuzzing in its standard tool
chain beginning in go 118 which makes go
the first major language to support it
natively
here's an example of what fuzzing looks
like in go first a fuzz test must be a
named function that starts with fuzz and
which accepts only a testing F argument
and no return value the fuzz test
contains a fuzz Target which is a call
to testing F dot fuzz and takes a
testing t as a first parameter followed
by the fuzzing arguments and again no
return value
there must be exactly one fuzz Target
per fuzz test and all seed Corpus
entries must have types which are
identical to the fuzzing arguments in
the same order
ready for more let's bring in Cody for a
deeper dive on fuzzing
thanks Cameron hello my name is Cody ass
and I'm a developer programs engineer at
Google
today I would like to walk you through
how we can take an existing application
and write fuss tests for it we'll start
by looking over the code base and then
we'll write some unit tests for that
code and then we'll see what it takes to
convert that unit test into a fuzz test
after this we'll take advantage of the
power of the fuzzing engine and see if
we can use it to uncover any bugs in our
code let's Dive In
today we will be working with this Bucky
calculator application our calculator
takes a string input and returns an INT
or an error
this string input is meant to be a
number an operator and another number so
just very basic calculator operations
here
as you can see from our code it parses a
couple of integers
and also the operator used to calculate
the result it then looks up which
calculation operator function to use
and then computes a result
let's start by generating a unit test
for this function
now let's add a few test cases to cover
the different types of operation our
calculator supports
I'm going to start by removing this args
type as we can simplify the code a
little bit as we'll just use the name
foreign
for our first test case
I am going to put four plus two
and that is equal to 6 and that is not
an error in case
now let's copy and paste this a couple
times and add a few more
4 minus 2 is 2.
4 times 2 is 8.
and last but not least four divided by 2
is 2.
let's also add one test case that we
know should fail
we will call this one fail
and it will fail
now let's give it a run and make sure
everything passes
great everything passes we're done right
well I bet we could be but I bet there
are a lot of cases that we aren't
covering by these five tests
let's see if we can convert this test
into a fuzz test and take advantage of
the fuzzing engine to find out if there
are any bugs in our code the first step
in changing this into a fuzz test is to
rename the function just as there is a
convention to name unit test starting
with the word test fuzz tests need to
start with the word fuzz
and they also take a different input
parameter they take a testing f
so rename that to f
there we go
now we have a fuzz test we need to write
a fuzz Target and also seat our existing
test cases to register our test cases
with the fuzzing target we can use the F
dot add method
this seated input can also be referred
to as a seed Corpus or Corpus entry
let's Loop over our test cases and add
each one
note that we are only passing our input
value into this corpse entry
next we will need to update our TDOT run
and transform it into an F dot fuzz to
register our fuzzing Target
you can also get rid of this loop at
this time
as we can see this function takes a
function with a testing T and A String
note it takes a string because this is
what we registered as our seed Corpus
if we had registered an INT this
function would need to accept an IT
these types need to align
now we need to refactor the body of our
test to work with the fact that we only
have an input value for this test and
not an actual result
in some cases you may be able to verify
the result of the function you're
calling by reverse engineering the
output to see if you can transform it
back into the input for instance
case though we are going to keep things
simple and see if buzzing our code can
reveal simple errors like panics so we
can get rid of this
we'll just verify that there's not both
an air and a value provided to got
and then we'll update our error message
accordingly
we'll call this statement
and we'll pass that in
now let's run this fuzz test with go
test
foreign
you can see that the output looks a
little different than before and now our
test cases are called seeds it should be
noted that you don't have to provide a
seed Corpus to your fuzz test but
if you do these seed values will be used
and run like a unit test with go test
although we have transformed our unit
test into a fuzz test we have not
actually done any fuzzing yet to do that
we need to use a different go test flag
we can additionally pass the dash fuzz
flag which takes a regular expression
for which fuzz test to run when fuzzing
the fuzzing engine will use a mutator to
constantly change the seed values
provided to our fuzz Target
this will then create a generated Corpus
that is Guided by code coverage to find
all the execution Paths of our code
being fuzzed let's try to fuzz our code
and see what all that looks like
foreign
yikes it looks like we already ran into
a bug let's take a minute and analyze
the output that the fuzzing engine
produced for us and see what is
happening
it appears that there are three
different tokens here but our middle
token is an empty string when we expect
it to be an operator there and what was
the error
the air is a runtime error invalid
memory address or nil pointer to
reference
and this is happening on line 24 of our
code
let's go check out the code
hmm
yep when we look up in our map there is
no entry for empty string for a function
call so it looks like we need to make
sure that our map has a value for this
we can add an okay check here
foreign
the great thing about when a fuzz test
fails is that it records the failing
result
this is then saved to the test data
folder which on future go test runs will
be used as a seed Corpus and run every
time as a unit test to make sure that we
never have a regression for this test
case again for this reason it is good to
check in this folder let's run go test
again and see if we fixed it
great it worked and you'll notice the
additional value provided into our seed
Corpus let's try to fuzz our code again
and make sure there's nothing else wrong
foreign
this time it's complaining about an
integer divide by zero error let's take
a look at our failing input
yep zero divided by zero is undefined so
let's see if we can go fix up the spot
in our code so that we never divide by
zero
so it's happening when we're calling our
operator so let's go down here ah yes we
are dividing by Y and in this case y was
Zero so let's add a if check here
and we're going to make this function
return an error now
so we're going to need to update the
signature
and the other return value
and let's see
now our operator type no longer matches
the signature because we added an error
to our divide
let's just add the air to all these and
there'll be no op operations for the
rest
foreign
we don't have to explicitly return nil
now let's run go test again and make
sure that we fixed it
all right let's fuzz one last time to
make sure that there are no more bugs in
our code
this time our fuzzing is taking quite a
bit longer to run so I'm going to say
that this is good enough for now
you can see from the fuzz run that there
are over 200 test cases that have been
saved to our generated Corpus which can
be found at go cash slash fuzz
you probably don't want to use fuzzing
to run forever in cases like these you
can use the fuzz time flag to specify
how long you want your target to fuzz
for
foreign
helped show you how that by spending a
few minutes and adding a fuzz test to
your code you can potentially find and
fix previously undiscovered bugs all
thanks to fuzzing
my little calculator app is now more
reliable and more secure
back to you Cameron
thanks for that demo Cody we hope you've
learned how to use vulnerability
management and fuzzing to better secure
your applications and go thanks for
joining us and enjoy the rest of your
time at Google Cloud next
foreign